[Applause]
well the Democrats wrapped up their case
about January 6th this week they think
that that's going to affect the midterms
hopefully I don't know about that we'll
talk about it with the panel uh Liz
Cheney as usual was terrific did you see
Liz Cheney there she had the answer
Liz Cheney getting Applause here in Los
Angeles it's an amazing world but at the
end she kind of said it all she said
without accountability It all becomes
normal and it will recur and the
Republican said finally some good news
oh my God
and did you see the new footage of Nancy
Pelosi like like in their little bunker
there
try I mean you could see these people
were desperate I mean she was calling at
the Army the National Guard anybody who
would come to help uh finally she called
the Uvalde Police Department it was
very touching drunk
and did you see on video where she's
talking about she says I hope Trump
comes to the Capitol if he does I'll
punch him out Nancy Pelosi's
uh I'm
don't be so sure who would win that
fight
beneath that hair and makeup is a total
badass and Pelosi's tough too
so and this says it all uh they
sentenced a family of five for storming
the capital families are doing this now
apparently some some guy and his wife
said let's storm the capital and bring
the kids
laughs
it's the first family trip where before
they go the dad said if anybody has to
go to the bathroom
hold it we're gonna need those
you're way ahead of me look at that he
said
we're gonna need those feces to smear on
the walls too late
but the big bombshell was at the end of
the last hearing they said they are
going to subpoena Donald Trump to appear
before
thank you
uh the odds that he will answer this
subpoena
the same as the odds that Britney Spears
will make a video where she's not
holding her tits with their hands I'm
just saying those are the odds you'd be
the judge
but of course when he got the subpoena
Trump was Furious he said you will be
hearing from my lawyer as soon as he
graduates from Law School
[Applause]